[Musik]
april
die blitze raus es ist gerade eur 45
da muss ja ausgeschlafen sein heute die
eigene pizza und deswegen steht oben auf
werbevideo war das ganze video wird
darüber handeln heute ist ja 17 17h
bereits mehrmals gesagt ich wollte man
eigene pittler aufgekommen also erfindet
winter aber auch für mich beim ausnehmen
der siebzehnte twitter ich habe gesagt
dass ich los eigentlich nur noch machen
wollte wenn irgendwelche sachen
passieren und wenn jetzt was ja schon
mal eine solche rost und ich glaube ich
nicht extra gemacht gleich ein treffen
bzw 1 kostenlos pizza verteilen an einem
live in köln das als bay
hierher kommt gleich rum und holt mich
erstmal zauberwort luca pizza ok möchte
den inserm kuschen
fick dich wir haben es satt
taxibestellung fahren jetzt zum grübeln
wir sind gerade im tiefkühlregal
angekommen und meine damen und herren
sie liegt hier
[Musik]
ich verteidige ein paar leise die 2000
jahre später versuchen aber später mit
hier tatsächlich nur 1900 werde ich auch
wieder voll betreibt dann haben wir hier
auch wieder ein paar vögel gibt sich
auch andere schützen
[Musik]
ich laufe so lang machen um einen block
und plötzlich jeder seite steht und mich
mit dem es die pizzen alle wieder zurück
geräumt wir werden sie natürlich in der
die musik ist bisschen komisch denn die
plätze wieder zurück geräumt werden
natürlich unsere eigene tiefkühltruhe
dafür am start robert falls euch jetzt
wirklich fragt halo kann eine prozent
eigentlich malt sich aus wie es die dem
kühlregal hier das dass es sie wir haben
ihren hype ist gott der euro belaufen
wir haben das rtl- interview jetzt
gerade fertig gemacht und werden uns die
jetzt an eine rewe kasse begeben denn
jetzt abscannen ich jetzt meine neuen
arbeitsplatz wird die ich mir meine
philosophie ist dass hier
[Musik]
konrad laser aus
ich habe gerade so eine pizza
draufgelegt und die soll eigentlich 410
diesen hier steht jetzt ist sie 4 164
gramm wiegt stell dich mal hier unten
unter die kamera dass ich hier den
bildschirm wird immer da ist er im
fernsehen
[Musik]
ich darf wieder gelogen immer das an die
pizza kommt dass hier einer oder das
denn sich jemand was kommt dass einige
sitzt man doch einen knopf drückt das
ist bankrott
es ist eines automatischen in was für
einer welt leben wir diese kostenlos
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so stehe ich mich denkt ja das ist ein
ganz normales telefon bei diesen telefon
habe ich eine nummer an und man kommt
eine durchsage durch den reese danke
danke vorschlägt
[Musik]
di luca pizza margherita heute können
sie ihren kaufen die nicht am liebsten
dieser klasse verstecken
hallo hier bin ich
zwar freuen er den zu wetter an und das
t shirt an das war bei
er ist zwölfter dem tier gerade
angekommen hallo darf also weil da wird
er will findet uns jetzt hier gerade im
aufenthaltsraum hier wird sonst immer
geraucht und danach nichts was auf jeden
fall am letzten part informationen
bekommen die pizza als ausverkauf in
diesem rewe der platz um es ist nicht
nur 15 uhr
aber der platz ist schon vollkommen
überfüllt und ihr habt heute die hotline
pommery höhe von central d b deutschland
komplett lahm gelegt also dann nichts
mehr es hat wahrscheinlich sehr sehr
viele leute von euch da anrufen können
wir die pizza ich will pizza und ein
komplett und hilfe habe ich jetzt noch
zwei interviews und danach werde ich
nach oben gehen und pizza verteilen
[Musik]
wir haben das interview jetzt auch
fertig das seht ihr auf youtube
nirgendwo und jetzt bewegen wir uns
endlich nach draußen und verteilen
blitzer so was geht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gerade heute da alle 90
ich kann hier autogramme geben und schon
schon mit sagen
leicht und dabei wahrscheinlich hier das
übermorgen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
klaus t
ja
gysi
es läuft gerade was mir vorgeworfen ich
schon jeden fall geben wir ihnen hilfe
zweier bilder und seine frau hinten
da hinten steht die polizei und das bist
du
[Musik]
danke
es tut mir leid das wird es nicht ganz
alle geschafft haben also ich habe mein
bestes getan aber es ist jetzt nach sex
blut über 35 schreiben aber es sind
immer noch ganz ruhig deswegen hab ich
den jungs gesagt dass ich jetzt in dem
blog backe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin live auf instagram der
livestream ist jetzt vorbei ich habe da
noch mal das ganze event heute
zusammenfasst übrigens habe ich das hier
unten alles ein bisschen um gewonnen das
schreibt das steht jetzt da die doppel
mit keyboard steht jetzt da hier so die
ecke gedacht aber vergebens auf jeden
fall habe ich mir etwas essen gestellt
weil während des gesamten events konnte
ich kein einziges inhalt zu essen weil
ich die ganze zeit mit bildern und so
beschäftigt war
ich habe mir gerade noch ein bisschen am
neuen mixtape gearbeitet
denn ihr jeden block gerade schaut ist
das sogar schon draußen
klickt man den beschreibungen da ist
mein neues mixtape mit
ich bin einfach ruhig ich habe jetzt
gerade den block geschnitten meine damen
und herren es ist gerade auf der burg
genau 2 uhr ich saß jetzt wirklich so um
die vier stunden in dem schnitt ich
glaube das hat man auch gesehen alleine
tier und musikuntermalung bei dem kern
treffen und so weiter und so fort und
die ich bin jetzt echt komplett am arsch
nicht möglich an der stelle noch mal
gedanken an alle die heute da waren ich
mich noch mal gedanken an die sieht die
leute die einfach einen mega mega geilen
job gemacht haben danke auch an den rewe
in der bonner straße ohne die das alles
nicht möglich gewesen wäre
danke auch an die polizei dass die
geguckt haben
das war keine massenpanik entsteht ich
fand den tag heute einfach mega ereignis
reich mega anstrengend aber andererseits
auch porträts schön also so viele von
euch zu treffen und einfach zu sehen so
wer hinter diesen ganzen aufruf zeilen
steckt so ich habe gerade im schnitt
echt also ich war kurz vor über diesen
ganzen szenen wo ich euch gefilmt haben
möchte es gar nicht ein riesiges
marketing mehr irgendwie politiker
machen oder jetzt am ende noch nach
werbung machen und dann irgendwie so
wenn durch die pizza gefällt wenn sie
euch schmeckt dann freut mich das wohl
wenn ihr euch nicht schmeckt dann ist es
auch vollkommen in ordnung ich habe mich
letztens in dem video so ein bisschen
aufgeregt das war einfach nur weil ich
jetzt noch nicht draußen war und ebenso
viel mühe gegeben haben alles umzusetzen
als
dieses nennt treffen und die logistik
der ganze sache und so weiter und so
fort wo mich also ein bisschen traurig
gemacht dass leute deswegen nicht
wertschätzen und dann ankommen von wegen
bevor die pizza quasi wirklich überhaupt
raus ist dass wir schon rummeckern und
das alles total grundlos und sinnlos und
das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden
auf jeden fall will ich den blog an
dieser stelle jetzt auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich jetzt noch nicht
schlafen weil ich das was ich jetzt
gerade noch auf nehme ja auch noch in
den block rat schneiden muss ich hoffe
euch hat die sache noch gefallen wenn es
getan hat will ich mich sehr sehr wohl
über einen live von euch freuen
rp und sonst würde ich jetzt sagen sehen
uns morgen an anderen video wieder meine
damen und herren in die morgige video
werde ich einen showcase game mal wieder
zocken aber bis dahin würde ich auf
jeden fall sagen haut rein und schaut
[Musik]